لا اخفيك امرا يعني بالعكس يمكن في زمننا
احنا كانوا يهتموا بالتربيه الفنيه اكثر
من الان انا تقلصت حصص التربيه الفنيه
انا انادي يعني من هذا الشرح انه بالعكس
تزيد تزيد الحصص هذه ضائق الفنيه لازم
تربى عند عند الجيل كيف شايفه الدور اللي
تقوم بالمؤسسات
الثقافيه المعنيه بالفن التشكيلي
مثلا عندك لو بنتكلم معهد مسك للفنون
لا دور كبير الان وفعال في الرياض
ويحتضن طبعا جميع الفنانين
وعدد الفنانين بازدياد يعني
الجمعيات جمعيات الثقافه والفنون يعني
يبغى لها دعم اكثر نحتاج الى دعم هي
الجمعيات لتدعم الفنانين
وزاره الثقافه مثلا تعمل دائما
نسميها
بعثات خارجيه
خارج المملكه
للفنانين
الاستفاده واخذ الخبره من الدول المتقدمه
وفي الفن قلت بوجه لهم رساله تفضلي اوجههم
لرساله هناك عدد كبير من الفنانين يبغى
يحتاجون الرعايه هذه شايفه انه يعني انا
نفسي بعد كفنانه احيانا تحدني وظيفتي يعني
تجيني دعوات خارج المملكه للمشاركه في
بيناله او مشاركه فيه ملتقى فني لكن ما
اقدر اطلع لانه ليس لدي اجازه لكن في
اجازات في
الديوان الخدمه المدنيه لكل موظف هناك
اجازه خارجيه دوليه يمثل المملكه فيها يجب
ان تفعل هذه الاجازات